and when we're told over and over and
over again nothing's more important than
family and the thing that my mother did
was she would point at people doing
exactly what she was doing and say i'm
not doing that look at how unhappy that
kid is
like you know you're like i'm not a
stage mom like that kid's stage mom is
it wasn't until like maybe three years
ago
i saw a movie
with a with a kid in it who was
one of my contemporaries when we were
kid actors and this kid if i said his
name every single person
uh of my age group who was going on
auditions would be like oh my god that
poor kid
and that kid's awful [ __ ] mother like
we all know this kid there are if
they're if our mutuals are listening to
this they're like they know exactly who
they know you're talking right i saw him
in a movie
and i had a flashback
like um
all of time compressed
and i was not sitting on the couch in my
game room watching this this kid in a
movie
i was
a little boy
in
the auditions
just hundreds of auditions where this
kid is every single time
and i can see
the fear and the sadness and the pain in
him in everything about him
wow
i i remember his mother smacking him
physically slapping him in the hallway
outside auditions
and screaming at him that he wasn't
whatever you know he just wasn't enough
one way or another and my mom
always making a really big deal about
how like well i'm not like that right
isn't that something you could have it
worse yeah you could have it worse you
have a house a roof over your head yeah
you don't eat every night it makes you
feel like oh my gosh i'm i'm acting like
an [ __ ] so i
in the midst of this movie
i suddenly realized that there's
just no difference between me and this
kid when we're little kids on auditions
the only difference is
my mom is on a is on better behavior in
public
my mom doesn't hit me but my dad does my
dad hits me all the time
but like my mom doesn't you know
she is
protecting her like investment i guess
you know she's like making sure that
this making herself look good in front
of the people that's the outside world
yeah like
one of her defining characteristics is
like what will the neighbors think you
know like it doesn't matter what the
truth is what do they think yeah so i
had this
i had this flashback that was
it was terrible and i spent a few days
in like a massive massive crisis because
of it and when i came through it and got
through the other side
it was like i had
i had admitted to myself and i had
confronted this thing that was really
painful and and had been like looming
over me my entire life which was that
huge lie
and that was when i realized
and it became a really crystallized
inside of me
that
i was never wrong
i was never
i was i was it was never my fault i was
no different than that kid
like he didn't want to be there i didn't
want to be there our mothers were making
us be there
the only difference is that
he
like his path took him into like you
know b movies and my path took me to
some place different
but
like as far as it goes as it relates to
our to our moms there was no difference
there